Deepak is a way to get diplomats or
civil servants and techies or coders and
software developers to work together on
a specific problem we try to match up
people with different backgrounds and
different ideas to form teams and to
start working on applications or
anything that can increase transparency
Europe well a lot of European open data
is available but not many people use it
yet so an event like this stimulates
people to know what's out there and
start to reuse it which we're trying to
harness the wisdom of the crowd here a
little bit I think and it's interesting
that we have people with different
profiles we have colleagues from the
different European institutions civil
society the tech community and I think
it's a really interesting mixture I like
very much the space and to be here at
the center of you policymaking it's an
inspiring place it's quite exciting
actually as are so many different
opinions and people trying different
things I think we'll all like leave this
place having learned something useful
and being able to put this into practice
afterwards
you were on the trip to Amsterdam to
present your application to the global
air transparency camp